I could take all day.
It's tuesday the seventeenth of the then the no need i need to weigh in and speaking with larry king. And i was very.
Bargained around. The battery. Be working out in him and. For the last three years. In an informal manner.
And formally. For the last four months.
Being axed by the oldest and indorsed by the oldest to get certain projects happening in naman
and particular a bunch a long way in which and. Community activities within them been in the culture.
I have if i just city. You know. When you think of a number that comes from word. Number one which is the hairy people.
Of a country and. Prior to that number. Who was a great a number a very wise man.
That does what every people have always been in this country. From time immemorial. And they were here.
When the beigel post arrived. That's the dark skinned people. We're talking about by evil. And i landed at evan tate.
There was another landing also at jamba. But this particular one that.
Evans had the bagel landed there and begin the process of settlement. Within this country and they came across.
The name on people at blue not that anybody. Which was a holy place in one. Jackie. School cycle.
And a war then erupted between the people. And the bible. And june the war.
People were pushed back down to the coast and. Tradition was then formed. Whereas the children. Of the beigel.
Who had certain leanings towards healing. Were taken to members and were then shall and. The healing sciences and.
Medicinal herbal use each and. Sacred law. And they were then taken back down to their people.
The bottle to instruct them in the. Immanuel was always a place for spirituality and healing. They should. Yeah. Yeah.
From an image that tells a bit. What with a lot of very gentle people there were vegetarian people.
They had on in jail. And like i said they've been here for a long time there are places. Underground places.
The sacred places. Of crystals of metals of healing places. And power places. They were taught by the anybody.
What was the significance that there was. Learnings within the rocks themselves on. Things are put to pass.
That still say new schools. It's sort of like a movie projector. I mean.
I can sit down and look at bubble gali which is a big the big rock. The first one. That scene from news mall and.
That is a chines the. Sculptures this oil paintings. Is photographs there is. It's a like a movie.
You can sit there and just watch a movie. If you say like from sunup to sundown.
And you can see the faces of figures that are animals that are different. The european.
And if i can see those things and i'm not the only one who have seen them.
Things in the rock they don't lose nations because they're created by natural causes. But light and shade.
And by texture. And so i want to someone so they're not listening. You know. And you know they're not under any.
Mushrooms or or anything like that. You know this seed with a with a with a clear bright. With clear eyes and.
If i could see the. Those things in the rock.
I know for sure and as a fact that the l people also saw what was in those rocks.
And it was no surprise to them when the european. People came into the country. That they recognized their faces.
And the animals. So some people say that in this. You know. When you know when it's a place with a prospect.
Can you tell us all. While nim been for a start wasn't a place where people went out there to settle full time.
While none of the old people did anyway. The war was in a state of movement. Moving around the country.
You know it was pretty boring. To stay in one place. You know you sort of.
It wasn't buying a half acre and having to pay off the bank. For the rest your feet life or.
You know it was free to go and move wherever they wanted.
And the fact that neighborhood was is that people went out there for specific purposes.
And that might take two years it might take three years for whatever purpose that was needed for them in their
development. Of exploration within themselves you know. Of human power. Or human abilities.
Not so much power but human abilities. And knowledge. And like i said that could happen.
You know six months it could happen in two years in three years could happen in four yes.
But you know then you moved on.
You know there were other places to explore there were other places to get knowledge from.
And there were places that they would in the area where. Where the women didn't go.
And not because that they were exempt from that place is because of the ability of the women
and their sensitivity to be have all to receive this knowledge and the power of these places.
From a distance that there was no need for them to go inside them. Or to go up to them. That was the men's business.
In that act of penetration or of confrontation.
The women had no need for that they received their full potency and power from a distance. Because that's their nature.
That's their sensitivity. So tell us a bit about that you both to be able the way you. Would you buy gold.
The children to buy gold with them. Because when they were given the title. Away and. By the numbers. What was there.
To heal and to teach sacred law. To the bible. Which is the knowledge of the earth.
That's a little and by god knew the law they knew the status the eye came from the sea.
They were quite familiar with the stars and with the sky dreams and. Of the sacred law in this country is.
Knowledge of the lad. That's sacred. In this sickness country.
Yes but what a sickness country is a country where you got to work to get rid of your sickness and.
That's anywhere in the country.
With a certain there is a designated sickness country that's not a place where you've got to get sick.
It's a place where you take a sickness to get rid of it because they areas within the country that have that power.
To take that sickness from you and dissipate it through the land. Because of that. It's true that in their tracks.
People. That's something you have to heal.
Well yeah it is a heavy sickness was out there in the middle of the mountain. You know there's big.
Drug abuse problems. I'm talking about drug abuse i'm talking about drugs.
People i'm talking to use drugs if they wish that. With proper knowledge.
But if you don't have a problem knowledge of drugs well you just.
Drug abuse and so there's drug abuse going on at the moment.
That's because of the draconian methods of the government and the state.
Loopholes that people are getting sicker and sicker. Because of a such a low.
It's not because of the law of the land the land is ailing all the time.
But if you have a social situation where a plant. Actually growing. Planet from the sea is apple and made illegal.
And it's the base of carol one. Trade and. Criminal activities within them than the law has to be changed.
That's a social law. And it's killing the people.
The laws of this land killing the people of the land is on the way and now. It's the sickness. Of it.
Sorry i was going to go but what we have to. I think what we have to get danny to tim.
Is the people's ability to look for culture. People's ability to come in contact and to learn. A culture that has laws.
And this is a problem must been in this country for a long time.
Is that they were people who've come from european descent who find it very hard to come to terms with certain laws.
Now they were say in him and for resistance. There are people who are interested in bundjalung. Culture.
They're interested in finding out what the l people did prior to invasion.
The condition that was here in the country prior to invasion was vastly different.
To the condition that has been in this country for the last two hundred g.'s. Now that's with so-called tribal law.
The law in this country. Had to be strict. Any civilization that's under. Attack. Or invasion. Tighten up. The laws.
They introduce martial law. So this country is being in a sense.
Under a form of martial law for the last two hundred g.'s. And so some people take it as being that.
This is aboriginal culture. That these are the laws of the aboriginal people here they owe.
Of course a lot of the aboriginal people. But they are the laws that want.
They're not the laws that we hear two hundred years ago prior to one. Yes they were different.
There was no need for a lot of the laws that are now within. Aboriginal society or culture.
But even so that there were still people who have no wish for. Laws. You know if.
Some women were told by the elders or by kore people that women are not supposed to go up to the rocks.
What do you get. You get groups of women. Going up to the rocks off the able to say. You can't go there.
And what do you know. Before you know it. You've got picnic this.
And you've got people on my she's going to those places. Because by sickly they were told not to go there.
So this is a state of lawlessness. People to tell the law. And for very good reason.
And so people deliberately go out of their way to go and break the law. So if people are going to have that attitude.
There's a lot of the elders are not happy with that attitude that if they tell people something about the culture
and about the laws of the land because these of the laws from the land and the law comes from the land.
Doesn't come from the people. Is transmitted by the people. So if the. You know the land. The.
The laws of the land atol to people in the people don't wish to have any. And the respect for that.
Well i just lose respect in the eyes of the able to settle
and so you find a situation where the old is just man talk about any such thing because they can see that these people
are really not interested in lord all. They're not really interested in culture.
They're by simply just interested in power than if they were bright this was something evil said to me i think. So yes.
Well people curse themselves by neglecting and by disregarding the laws that were given by the elders and why.
You know that curse doesn't come from the elders or from the people at all.
I certainly didn't go around cursing people. You know people have respect there's no need to curse.
It's only when those people have disrespect that they curse themselves.
You know is personal responsibility we're talking about here.
And that's a very strong mind stay within the party culture. Is personal responsibility for your actions.
And if you don't have responsibility for your actions where you are cursed. You do that to yourself. No one else.
No one else is the guy for that. You know the land has a slow.
And if you wish to transgress those laws or to dis disregard them. Well you're cursing yourself. That's all.
And you know it's been it's people it's it's people have disregard the laws of the cursing themselves with poisoned
water. You know the cursing themselves with the with the hate from the.
Cutting down of the rain forest or the cursing themselves with putting cattle on the.
The cursing themselves with the poisons in their foods. The cursing themselves. People not cursing them for that.
In the story of writing this. Well the rainbow serpent is like up a snake. Yes i'm telling but.
And that's a piece of the rainbow serpent. And bought a cop it's like about one in the same and.
That was a very strong center for the brain by snake dreaming in the newman valley. It's crystals.
Because they cycle to group of rambus like the crystal. In the moon and. So that was another place where.
Like i said with a healing. For all forms of feeling that comes under the carpet snake of rambus night.
All of these things that you telling me. Interesting stories. Nothing's changed. No you know. They can change.
The dreaming is can be added to by stick with the story remains the same. But they can be added to.
They can be given another perspective. Because it was so many. You've got three sixty three sixty degrees.
And you can take any one of those paths. But whatever path you take. There's a dreaming story for that.
Because the al people have gone on that path some time people throughout the history of this country.
People have been there. That being and i've done that.
So i would nothing has really changed in this country as far as like us.
Because no matter where you go in this country. It's been walked before someone had been. Along that same track.
But your following. So in other words. There's already been someone i hate of you who has been.
So you're just following there try. No matter where you go.
And i'm not just talking about like human form but a good homosapien for. You know in a totem way. You know.
Totem your totem. As being that way.
You know we never visit for ordinates night for morning that booed from the waterfall. You've been there.
You've been through that way before. Nothing has changed.
So it's no surprise to hear that with this sort of people taking the ideas that had been there before.
There is the dreaming stories like i was saying with the. Beigel people and with the nimble people and.
That's still occurring. That's still happening. And there is a. There's a happy ending. There's a happy ending to it.
If people like as if people want to learn the culture. And i want to learn the language. Now the language.
In the name of the area. And up in the bunch and miria. As being given the go ahead by the old has to be taught and.
They teaching it. So the language needs to go out and when people start learning the language of the land.
The indigenous language. They then automatically. Have a deed. To the land. As far as their standing. Of that land.
You speak the language. You're bundjalung. Which you're speaking the language. You speaking bundjalung.
Which and you learn in the language. You learn in the dremiel in the significance of the language.
Because the language gives a specific. References to the cycle places. And what they mean. I can talk.
And explain things in english until my face goes blue. But in that the.
If you learn by angela than i talk to you when bundled with a old as a talking to you when you learn.
You get the full import of one word. What. The other influences. On the spirit level. On the earth level.
In the water level. On all of these things. So that gives do. A sort of like a deed. Of sharing. The lane and.
It's called. Nothing which is alice. Then it becomes alice. Not yours and mine.
Which is the situation that exists now and. It's very important to learn the language. So people listening to this.
Talk or whatever that. If they can make an effort to learn the language of their local area.
And to approach the people in the old is. For that and. And to keep that culture and language.
Happening within their communities. As it is up here in the bundjalung.
There won't be as much confusion about land rights. Because it comes from the rights of the land the land has rights.
These are the lns rights. People the human beings. The human dreaming. Is to maintain.
And to respect the laws of the land and. The rights of building.
And if people don't enforce or if they show a lack of interest in the lands rights. Well we all die.
That's as simple as that. Because the land. Is the low and no human being is greater than the law.
Well there was a tradition of people coming from far and wide from the far reaches of this continent coming to him
and for giving. Given out ability to fly.
Now people can interpret as all sorts of things that would have a physical process of the talking about
when they say fly. Well yes. We all people did. Physically move through the. But that was a time back then.
That was a time back that..
There's different ways to move through the and now with it having to balance up and down on your pointy like t.m.
Sorry my age. But you know like there's other ways. There's other means to fly through the air.
I mean people can do that physically now
when he went through you know what planes all through with flying a car to whatever you know doing doing stuff like
that. I mean that's the people that sal down the rock. And so on and so on. That's done physically.
What was some of the others. Secrets. There is nothing.
Right for us to just say we're talking about this two hundred year period
when the old people had no need as such for specific people. To take care of their healing.
And to have responsibility for someone else's health. I mean that.
That was everyone's responsibility for their own health in the way. And the way that was.
That the al people lead their lifestyle any way excluded. Sickness. And so on.
And if people do come down with a sickness. Is that the. You know there was a family. Remedies. Plant knowledge.
Where they can just go and fix themselves up by a feeling a little bit to have sorts. Or stuff of.
Nothing major but within this to want to do period because of the sickness that did come to this land.
There were people who were specialized who had to become specialized. And so.
Look i'm saying with this martial law business. Now there were people who specifically became warriors.
People who specifically. Were designated we and. Some who specifically designated. Other tasks.
Because like i said it was oppressive times and. People were concerned with just surviving.
So there were people who who were given the tasks of being custody. Of certain knowledge is. So i wanted to tell.
Because the majority of people were concerned with with surviving. With with hiding. And running.
So it's a tradition not smallest. It has been amplified i lost only g.'s.
With certain people were given the training for healing is that story as it has a happy ending how do you think about
what you think i had a strong faith in him and people in him and will.
Well i already have i'm in this situation know that in the last twenty years where people were exploring.
Time day of dealing with. Alternative thinking. And methods of war to the powers and. And so on it's own. You know so.
That's a happy story. Sometimes it wasn't the same as this in the dreaming story. Where the people were taken.
Who are app costs by sickly from the invading people and they were taken by a to newman and they were taught.
Medicine and. Toward healing. To take back down to their people. And so i could law. You know given the sacred law.
And things like that. To to take to the people to heal them to fix them. You know. To say that.
You know it's going to be all right. You know like don't panic. The human spirit is the most resilient.
Thing in the universe. Place. Yeah. Sounds good right.